acting is a job and like any job there
are days where you're just going through
the motions to get that sweet sweet
paycheck so whether it's actors who were
slumming it for the money or just doing
some work until the next prestige
project came along we've got to look at
some stars who were just too good for
their movies Michael Caine and jaws the
revenge when he was asked to appear in
the fourth installment of the once-proud
Jaws franchise Roy Scheider is rumored
to have said quote Satan himself could
not get me to do jaws part for believe
it or not the actual premise of this
movie is that a great white shark is
exploiting a completely unexplained
psychic connection to Ellen Brody in
order to get revenge for the death of
the shark in the original Jaws hints the
tagline this time it's personal Michael
Caine who plays a character named hoagie
missed out on receiving his Academy
Award for Best Supporting Actor and
Hannah and her sisters the first Oscar
he actually won after three nominations
because he was on location for reshoots
- jaws for when asked about the film
later he had the right perspective on
the whole thing I have never seen it but
by all accounts it is terrible however I
have seen the house that had built and
it is terrific Jeremy Irons and Dungeons
& Dragons Academy Award winner Jeremy
Irons is a natural villain even when
playing an animated lion in a Disney
movie for babies when he played prophy
on the villainous wizard of the 2000
Dungeons & Dragons movie well let's just
say he rolled a natural one on his
subtlety check rather than attempting to
bring all the fun stuff about the game
to life the people behind the film ended
up with a monumentally generic fantasy
setting where the most likeable
character was Marlon Wayans as a
cowardly thief named snails but irons
doesn't let the material drag him down
his performance is a master class and
scenery-chewing
he's clearly having fun even if the
audience isn't Sir Ben Kingsley in
BloodRayne in 1982 Sir Ben Kingsley
starred in Gandhi a film that was
nominated for 11 Academy Awards in 1/8
including Best Actor for Kingsley 23
years later Kingsley joined a cast that
included Billy Zane and meatloaf for
BloodRayne the film adaptation of a
video game that isn't even the fifth
best movie about a half vampire
it's another fine entry in the Canon of
OVA ball the director responsible for a
string of notoriously terrible videogame
flicks that were essentially made to
exploit a loophole in German tax law
that set Kingsley doesn't exactly help
matters while he's clearly capable of
much more he plays the villain of the
film is called into motionless but the
Tellez men joined which is a nice way of
saying that it seems like everything he
says is read from a script he's seen for
the first time William marshal in
Blacula William Marshall was a
classically trained Shakespearean actor
who was once hailed by the London Sunday
Times as the best Othello of our time
unfortunately he's far more famous for
playing the title role in 1972 s Blacula
and it's amazingly titled sequel screen
Blacula scream now make no mistake
Blacula is actually a pretty awesome
movie and even Stan's is one of the
first horror movies to star a black
actor in the lead role Marshalls
performances mama Wald a and African
prince who strikes a deal with Dracula
and ends up as a vampire himself is
downright commanding Marshall reportedly
insisted that the character be written
with dignity rather than as a bumbling
punchline it was even commercially
successful writing the early 70s
blacksploitation movement to become one
of 1972's highest-grossing films that
said it's still a movie in which his
performance is elevating the material
rather than the other way around
Cate Blanchet in Indiana Jones in the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull well this
is embarrassing it looks like someone
made a mistake in the notes for this
video and accidentally wrote that there
was a fourth Indiana Jones movie where
Indy fights aliens and has a son played
by Shia LaBeouf even though we're pretty
sure there were only three movies in
that series if however there was a
fourth Indiana Jones movie
Kate Blanchet would have definitely been
too good for it especially if it was
released in 2008
well after Blanchette had won an Academy
Award for Best Actress then again
everyone in such a movie would have been
slumming it which is probably why it
definitely never happened ever Bob
Hoskins in Super Mario Brothers Super
Mario Brothers should have worked and
Bob Hoskins is almost perfect for the
part of Mario admittedly he's not
Italian and like any actor he was
probably very nervous about stepping
into the role so brilliantly defined by
captain Lou albano Hoskins his
performance in Who Framed Roger Rabbit
is brilliant and if he can pull that off
then pretending to stomp on koopa
troopas should be a piece of cake right
unfortunately that's not what happened
Mario Brothers is a pretty difficult
story to screw up but the filmmakers
somehow managed to drop the ball so hard
that it registered on the Richter scale
instead of a fun romp
it's an incomprehensible modern dystopia
full of terrifying nightmare monsters
and also Dennis Hopper in a mud bath for
some reason Raul Julia and street
fighter street fighter might not be a
good movie in the traditional sense but
it's also ridiculously fun and Raul
Julia's genuinely amazing portrayal of
m.bison is responsible for about 99
percent of that
saying he's going over the top with his
performance doesn't quite cover it
because that implies that he somehow
going beyond with the material demands
that's not what's happening here at all
the movies version of bison is the kind
of megalomaniac who has an entire
financial plan based upon printing up
his own money and then kidnapping the
Queen of England in order to set up the
exchange rate
sadly streetfighter was also Julia's
last movie apart he took despite
suffering from stomach cancer because
his children were fans of the game but
while his death at the height of his
career is truly tragic Julia's
performance is beautifully on Iran eclis
fantastic for fans of schlock it's one
of the most fun self-aware and endlessly
quotable performances ever to grace a
goofy video game adaptation but for Raul
Julia
it was Tuesday Sir Patrick Stewart in
the emoji movie finally there's this you
had to know this was coming
Sir Patrick Stewart legendary
Shakespearean actor famous for bringing
Captain jean-luc Picard and Professor X
to life star of stage and screen
patron saint of pop culture and
all-around super talented guy literally
plays a talking pile of poop in a movie
about emojis is such a loaded no go
ahead
finish that sentence there's literally
nothing to add to that thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Applause]
[Music]